y que se respeten los derechos de los
migrantes en eeuu ese es el pedido de un
grupo de activistas que protestó en los
ã ngeles sede de la cumbre de las
américas
estamos enviando un mensaje al
presidente de bailén para que cumpla con
sus promesas y extienda el estatus de
protección temporal a las personas que
llevan más de 20 años viviendo aquí y
siguen en el limbo
y queremos que trabaje y exija que se dé
la residencia permanente
la migración es tema determinante en la
cita que reúne a los presidentes de
países de norte sur y centroamérica con
excepción de venezuela cuba y nicaragua
pero fueron invitados méxico y honduras
también están ausentes pero aunque
actores fundamentales de la crisis
migratoria no asisten se espera que la
declaración de los ángeles refleje
acuerdos importantes para dar solución a
la crisis migratoria en la región y
mientras la cumbre avanza en el norte
del continente miles de migrantes
avanzan en caravana por tapachula hasta
la frontera estadounidense
que lo escuché bien yo baile pero
escuché a 3 manuel lópez obrador que la
escuche nicolás maduro
daniel ortega
[Aplausos]
compañeros
como quiera
miles de emigrantes se movilizan en
caravana por tapachula hasta la frontera
estadounidense pero el gobierno de
andrés manuel lópez obrador ya envió a
efectivos de la guardia nacional para
bloquearlos desde hace meses parte de
los migrantes que viajan en la caravana
han esperado en tapachula un permiso de
movilidad sin respuesta